Season 2 of Supergirl saw the show fly over
to the CW to join its fellow DC TV shows and
introduced a bunch of brilliant new characters
including Tyler Hoechlin as Superman, Floriana
Lima as Maggie Sawyer, and Chris Wood as Mon-El.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video I'm going to break down
some of the coolest easter eggs and connections
to comic books, superhero shows and movies
that I found in season 2 of Supergirl.
By the way, I've got an epic Super-Flarrow-verse
giveaway on my Supergirl, Flash, and Arrow
videos.
For a chance to win any of these Funko Pops,
make sure you subscribe and leave a comment
about the show's easter eggs or season finale.
Quick warning: there are spoilers ahead, so
if you want to avoid those, come back when
you've caught up with Season 2!
Now that the series has put a face to its
Man of Steel, there've been even more Superman
references this season, right from the opening
episode which was named The Adventures of
Supergirl in tribute to the 1940s radio show,
1950s TV series, and later comic book series,
The Adventures of Superman.
And that popular 1940s radio show also gave
us the phrase 'up, up, and away' when Superman
soared off into the skies.
And that phrase gets an airing at the end
of episode 1 when Clark and Kara say it before
flying off together, and again in episode
21, when Cat Grant urges Supergirl to get
on with rescuing Mon-El and Lena Luthor.
Speaking of Cat Grant, the way she reacts
when she sees Clark at CatCo and the fact
he says he has 'some sway with' her are playful
nods to the comic book series The Adventures
of Superman, where the gossip columnist Cat
first appeared in the late 1980s as a romantic
partner for Clark Kent.
And the name of Cat's new assistant, Miss
Teschmacher, is a shout-out to the first two
Superman movies with Christopher Reeve where
Teschmacher was also the name of Lex Luther's
assistant and love interest.
And amusingly enough, Cat Grant shouts Miss
Teschmacher's name in the same way that Gene
Hackman's Luthor did in those movies.
In episode 15, after Kara's fired from CatCo,
she explains why she's upset to Mon-El, saying,
'Supergirl is what I can do; Kara is who I
am'.
This echoes Clark Kent's words to Lois Lane
in the second season of the 1990s TV series
Lois & Clark, which is brilliantly fitting
as not only does this episode of Supergirl
feature Dean Cain but also Teri Hatcher, who
starred as Clark and Lois in that TV show.
There are more cool references to iconic DC
characters in the episode 'Welcome to Earth',
with an especially nice homage to Lynda Carter's
Wonder Woman when Supergirl is on fire and
puts out the flames by imitating Carter's
famous Wonder Woman spin.
By the way, Lynda Carter, who plays President
Olivia Marsdin on the show, even gave Melissa
Benoist some tips for the scene, showing her
how she did her classic twirl!
There's also another sly wink in that episode
to fans of Carter's Wonder Woman, when Supergirl
says how impressed she is to have seen Air
Force One, and the President replies, 'if
you think that's cool, you ought to see my
other jet', a delicious reference to Wonder
Woman's invisible jet!
By the way, the President's name, Olivia Marsdin,
is also a little hat-tip to Olive Byrne, one
of the inspirations behind Wonder Woman, and
to Wonder Woman's creator, William Moulton
Marston.
Oh, and the President's hairstyle in episodes
17 and 21 is a little throwback to Lynda Carter's
look as Diana Prince in her 70s TV series.
Mehcad Brooks got to suit up this season as
Jimmy Olsen took on the mantle of the Guardian,
a DC character who first appeared in issue
7 of Star Spangled Comics when a cop called
Jim Harper became a vigilante.
And during Guardian's first appearance in
episode 6, there's a nod to his character's
comic book origins thanks to Winn's van which
has the words Star Spangled Delivery Company
emblazoned on it, along with the year 1941,
which is when the first issue of Star Spangled
Comics was published.
Oh, and the number 204 on the van is a reference
to the last issue published in the retitled
Star Spangled [War Stories] series.
Plus, in the following episode, Guardian catches
a thief who's just robbed a store called Newsboy,
which is a shout-out to the Newsboy Legion,
a boy gang who appeared alongside Guardian
in the comics.
The title of the mid-season premiere, "Supergirl
Lives" is a shout-out to the episode's director
Kevin Smith and his script for the abandoned
1990s movie "Superman Lives", which was going
to be directed by Tim Burton and star Nic
Cage as Superman.
And there's another sneaky reference to that
cancelled film when Mon-El tells Supergirl
that the alien Jo Gunraf is cooking up Thanagarian
snarebeast.
When Kevin Smith was developing the Superman
Lives script, producer Jon Peters insisted
there should be a scene where Superman battled
a giant spider, and the planned name for that
spider was a Thanagarian Snare Beast.
Season 2's also brought us a nice sprinkling
of Batman references.
In the Fortress of Solitude, just before Supergirl
sets the Atomic Cauldron to blow up herself
and Mr Mxyzptlk, she tells the fifth-dimensional
imp that she's had enough of his games, and
adds, 'You wanna get nuts?
Let's get nuts!'
That line is straight from Tim Burton's 1989
Batman movie and was said by Michael Keaton's
Bruce Wayne as he flew into a rage with the
Joker.
And in episode 20, City of Lost Children,
there's a humorous nod to the Caped Crusader
and the Man of Steel's fraught relationship
in both the comics and the movie, Batman vs
Superman: Dawn of Justice, when James laments
that people he tries to help are scared by
his Guardian outfit.
'People see this big guy in a scary mask and
they run away, just like Clark's friend,'
says James.
To which Winn replies, '… I feel like they're
more frenemies.'
Of course, there are tons more easter eggs
and references in the show, but what were
your favourites?
And what did you think of the season finale
and what are you looking forward to seeing
in season 3?
Be sure to leave a comment and subscribe for
a chance to win one of these cool Funko Pops,
which I'm giving away on this Supergirl video
and on my upcoming Flash Season 3 and Arrow
Season 5 easter egg videos.
If you enjoyed this video, do please like
and share it, and check out more of my easter
egg and DC videos by clicking or tapping the
screen here!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee ki-yay, movie lovers!